we got another phone call right now okay
let's uh let's go quick the Reggie in
Denver Reggie and Denver you're here on
the Rich Eisen show Reggie yeah this is
Reggie
which is the China must not be there
this is me Reggie how are you this mr.
October hearing in June yeah this is how
are you wretch oh hey how about you I'm
good I'm good I'm good
how's it going good I'm good I'm well
I'm going to New York I got a little
crossways there with uh when they wanted
me there and I asked me to be there
tonight at like 7:00 and so I said I'm
not getting out till 10:00 and so uh
well let me see what I could do I got on
a 6:30 flight for the Yankees there you
go I can be there on time or something
that they want me to do so you know what
they want you to do Reggie you want to
see them watch the knock them the cover
off the ball 23 straight games of the
home run and karna Jones already hit a
couple judge returns tonight what do you
think of this lineup Reggie I love it I
love the lineup at the same time I'm
really not as focused on the lineup as I
am what we're doing with our pitching
because in postseason you got a pitch
and I'm looking at you know the Houston
Astros and they're pitching it a little
bit better than our so right now we've
got a my focus is on pitching I know I
know we're going to score run but we've
got to stop the other guys score
fantastic hey reg you know I I know I'm
gonna be up against it the break is
coming and I don't want to end up
cutting you off so I just want to tell
you what what you've meant to me I mean
you know this is my 50th birthday here
what you've meant to me what you meant
to me as a kid you got me into baseball
you you did and I have a love of that
sport more than anything else and what
you did and how you went about your
business and a crazy-ass time in New
York City I will never forget it reginal
Martinez Jackson yeah I do appreciate it
my friend and when uh they called and
said can I call in we got to talk about
your birthday bro yeah you got uh 50
coming this is the last one you're gonna
have you don't want any more well you
know what you you are sir the straw
that's stirring my celebration drink
today Reggie that's you the sad thing
about it I appreciate that rich is that
thing about it is that as you get older
or that's like and you like everybody
knows your name they're going to oh
happy birthday 73 today
Wow can you believe it you're the best
reg thanks for calling in as you're
making your way to New York and as I
tell you I'd love to have you here in
Los Angeles I want to spend as much time
with you as I possibly can
I will get your show over there and if I
don't see you bro I can always hear you
on the radio I can always see you on TV
during the football season which I enjoy
I love your show and say hello to Susie
I will and take a listen to my show I'm
on in Saturday morning okay it's
something it's not a fact I'll get you
on my shoulder bar if you want to go on
in
Reggie done what like 8 o'clock
California you got it you hang on right
now I'm gonna hop out because I'm gonna
throw to break our to a Daryl Morey the
Houston Rockets general manager coming
up I'm gonna hop on well it shall give
you my number and we'll do it thanks for
calling in reg that's Reggie Jackson on
the show for more of the Rich Eisen show
tune - audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
for free on BR Live or download the Rich
Eisen show app